so the united states has reportedly
conducted a raid in syria
targeting the isil leader abu bakr al
baghdadi we have these
exclusive pictures just in of the
aftermath of the raid on a house in the
province of
idlib there are conflicting reports we
have to say about whether this operation
was a success or not but the
u.s magazine newsweek is citing a u.s
army official
who says baghdadi was killed
48 year old iraqi though has been
reported dead several times before
now ahead of the u.s media reports the
president donald trump
tweeted this just one line something
very big
has just happened the white house says
trump will make a major announcement at
1300 hours gmt sunday which is
uh just under five hours from now
so here's our team to talk through this
we'll be with zaina khoda in the
lebanese capital
beirut for a bit of background in a
moment but we're starting with natasha
hernan
in the iraqi capital baghdad zaina in
the absence of confirmation
from the americans so far what have we
learned about the actual raid itself
are you talking to me kamal i'm sorry i
didn't hear you yes go ahead natasha
yeah
okay i thought you said zaina um look if
in fact al baghdadi
is dead this would be a huge
coup and a welcome one for the united
states and
its allies for years there has been a
manhunt
4l baghdadi a 25 million dollar bounty
on his head
for years there have been many raids by
the united states and its allies in an
attempt
to capture al-baghdadi again we do not
have confirmation
uh that he is in fact one of the senior
terrorist leaders that's a direct quote
from uh army officials in the united
states who were killed
during this raid but we do believe based
on the telegraphing that's coming from
trump
the nature of the white house
announcement on a sunday at 9 00 a.m in
the morning washington d.c
time that for sure whatever this news is
the u.s
administration certainly considers it
big news
this is what we know that an elite group
with the us
army was assisted by the central
intelligence
agency with reconnaissance and
intelligence gathering
on the ground they went into a compound
in
idlib in syria that's in the northwest
portion
of syria it's quite near the uh
syria-turkey border during this raid
sources are telling american
news outlets that a man detonated a
suicide
vest and that is what um uh where all
these uh
information is circulating that the the
man who
detonated that suicide vest was in fact
the head of isil it's a bit unusual by
the way uh analysts are saying that he
would have been hiding out
in idlib there are uh other armed groups
in idlib
that are considered rivals of isil not
allies but also
with this fluid situation on the ground
in syria isil fighters
had also been fleeing um to the idlib
area so perhaps
if baghdadi isn't uh was in fact in that
area
he might have attempted to take refuge
with these isil fighters
and natasha reaction anything from the
iraqis so far
well as you can imagine uh if in fact
al-baghdadi is dead this is going to be
extremely welcome news here in iraq
baghdadi
was in iraqi he began his so-called
caliphate
in 2014 in mosul and then wreaked havoc
on the country and affected the lives of
millions here alone the iraqi government
is planning to make a statement of its
own
later on today iraqi television is
already circulating pictures
of this raid and what we're hearing is
that there's already a crisis here in
the country with the
government fighting for its survival
there are thousands who have been on the
streets once again this month
um uh protesting against the government
asking for the government to resign and
what uh
analysts are saying is that this could
be a moment for the iraqi government
to divert the attention away from these
domestic issues
if in fact baghdadi was killed to
portray this as a victory
and one in which they played a role in
iraqi government is reminding people
that it has worked alongside the united
states and the u.s load coalition to
defeat isil
by uh offering uh intelligence gathering
and assistance
natasha name there in baghdad thank you
apologies for the confusion before but
we are going to talk to zaina
now who is in the lebanese capital
beirut for a bit of um
a background on the man himself how he
rose to power
zainab quite so quickly and well more to
the point how isil
under his leadership moved quite so
quickly back in 2014.
well he was the man behind isil's
expansion
and creation the roots of isil
is from al-qaeda in iraq abu bakr
al-baghdadi was the leader of al-qaeda
in iraq in 2010.
how was he able to expand control and
gain
all this power well he exploited two
things first of all
the security vacuum in neighboring syria
at the time
many areas in northern syria were
outside the control of the government
there was a war and he managed to
exploit this to be able to regroup to
attract fighters to
to recruit fighters because what he
relied on
was exploiting the grievances of the
sunni population
both in iraq and syria in iraq
it was a shia led government was in
control of the country
the security forces were really
most of the sunni population in the
center of iraq they were afraid
of the security forces they were afraid
of the government in neighboring syria
it was the same thing the sunnis felt
that they were under attack
by an alawite-led government which is
backed by iran so he used those two
things he exploited the security vacuum
and he exploited the grievances of the
sunni population and soon
he took control of territory in syria in
iraq
taking over cities declaring the islamic
state of iraq and the levant
but soon people started to turn against
him because of the way
his fighters were were dealing with the
people they were oppressing people
they were imposing a very strict
interpretation
of islamic law and he was also under
fire from
rebel groups syrian opposition rebel
groups who did not believe in the
creation of
of this islamic state he also had
differences with
al-qaeda in syria so he was up against
he had
a lot of enemies and of course the
us-led coalition with the help of
kurdish fighters both in syria and in
iraq
managed to take control of territory
from his group and
they were fighting for their last
stronghold in march this year
in bahrus which was just a small town
they lost control of the town in march
really declaring the us declared the
territorial defeat of isil
but then we saw a month later baghdadi
appear in a video his first video
in five years trying to rally support
saying that we have not been defeated
and just last month a purported audio
message from
the isil leader so he was really behind
the group's expansion and creation uh
but
if indeed his death has been confirmed
it will be a blow to the group
which really has suffered a lot of
losses in recent years
beirut thank you we'll continue the
conversation with marwan kabalan
director of
policy analysis at the arab center for
research and policy studies maybe we can
just pick up on what we were
saying with zainab there what zaina said
at the end of their answer how much of a
blow it will be to isil because
with any group like this with a isil
group or an al-qaeda group
if the leadership is decapitated it is a
big loss but these groups are bigger
than one person
well you're absolutely right i think
it's a big blow to to isil
losing its leader
but as you said i mean this is a
not very centralized organization
in the sense we don't have a very clear
hierarchy here that
one leader is actually controlling
all the branches and all the people that
are part of the
organization so we have seen actually
many uh
attacks uh in different places
not taking orders from alberta himself
actually but people acting on their own
initiative
so uh a big blow indeed but it's not the
end of the
uh of the organization especially
the motives which have created or led to
the creation of isil are still very much
there
anger negligence
exclusion especially of the sunni
population in syria and iraq
and many other places around the region
so i think they will
remain active for
for many years to come but very much
weakened absolutely
well how strong would you describe isil
as being now i know that's a very
broad question because it's a across a
very wide area
i think yeah i think we have to
differentiate two levels here we are if
we are talking about the military
operational level
it has been weakened a lot because uh it
has been
i mean defeated in in syria and in iraq
to a great extent
they lost their capital in raqqa they
lost they lost al musa in 2017
they lost most of the territories they
gained starting in 2000
2013 2014 but
if we are talking about the intellectual
ideological level it's a completely
different issue because the idea is
still very much alive
as i said as long as the motives
the the causes which have actually led
to the rise of the organization
are still very much there unless we deal
because security approach is not
is not the cure to the phenomena of isil
i think we have to deal with it
in a in a different way and don't forget
today that we have a whole camp in syria
and this camp in my opinion if we don't
deal with it
in a very smart way because you have
all the children and women of isil are
held there
without schools without services without
any sort of supervision
so if we don't actually deal with this
camp and many other
uh uh such places uh that have been left
been left actually by after the defeat
of isis i think we are gonna see more of
those people
getting recruited by by the organization
these kids who are today
10 or 12 years old in five five six
seven years
they will become grown up and i think
they will become a very
important pool of recruitment for for
isil if we don't deal with this
in a in a very smart way and all
potentially exacerbated by other events
in syria like the
withdrawal of u.s forces absolutely uh
and also i mean don't forget that uh
if you have the regime the syrian regime
taking control back of most of these
territories without changing the
approach
which in the first place have led in the
first place have led to the rise of isil
i think that
resentment will remain there and
resentment is
in my opinion the major issue that we
have to deal with here
if we want to uh eliminate isil
completely on the ideological level
marwan kabul and thank you for now we'll
talk to you again later on hopefully as
we get some more information
on this story thank you